my name is Harold you i'm a partner at
orrick or a global law firm I represent
many companies I represent a lot of
mobile companies in the mobile companies
I represent her some of the most fun I
work with and the reason it's it's you
know creates a lot of interest for me
personally is because it is one area
where we it seems like the developments
and then of with the things we talked
about here today really do touch us
immediately and make an an amazing
impact on a lot of people so a really
fun space to be involved in I thought
what we would do is introduce the panel
and then maybe start with a few kind of
high-level topics and maybe take it from
the angle of looking at the mobile
industry today from the perspective of
the various constituents I think the
goal here is to be very interactive I
hope that all of you are you know
willing to participate in that so if you
have questions please let us know so why
don't we just begin by having each of
the panelists introduce themselves
briefly maybe just tell us who you are
you're what you're doing and maybe some
kind of internet your thoughts on the
mobile world so syriac once you sir okay
hi very nice to be here I'm here because
I love mobile and I'm like building
mobile companies this is my third one
right now that i'm i'm attempting to
build it's called shopkick and it's a
company that was started with kleiner
perkins as i fund which works together
with apple and reid hoffman as in as
investors and we're trying to bridge the
mobile and the physical retail world
because from our perspective that's
really where one of the biggest
opportunities lies ahead so that's me
nice to be here ah my name is Bob tanker
I run a company called mobile iron we're
funded by sequoia Norwest and storm
ventures the we actually work on
something that's relatively boring in
the mobile industry but actually a
gigantic opportunity and that's actually
the enterprise
for a little context there's 50 million
smartphones being shipped into the
enterprise this year and the enterprise
is really struggling it's relatively
underinvested from a start-up
perspective it's not very sexy but I got
to tell you it's a big problem customers
will pass money for it so that's what
makes it interesting yeah and i think
the comment on the general structure of
the mobile industry is that
fundamentally power is being
redistributed really quickly the pace of
change is breathtaking if you think back
to what the mobile industry look like
even a year ago it already looks
different and that just makes this
really fun my name's steve hoffman and
i've been in the mobile industry a while
so I've seen this change happen at a
very fast pace like you were saying I
was ran the mobile games group at info
space I actually worked with syriac back
in the day and I started a mobile
venture-funded mobile startup called
Zano which is out there doing well and
now I'm doing another startup I'm
actually doing a couple things we have a
new product that's about to launch and
its focus is helping developers solve
their biggest problem out there right
now and for every mobile startup and
developer it's really how do I get new
users how do I get users download and
use my application you know on the
iPhone the Android and other platforms
so we're working on solving that one
fundamental problem and then I'm also
working with Qualcomm on a really neat
project that I can't talk about yet so
I'm not allowed to yeah so my name is
Lee Linden and last year at this time I
was actually at mba student here the GSB
and during my second year I started with
my co-founder of Tapjoy just building
mobile applications for iphone and for
Android and we quickly learned that
there's a set of challenges associate
with building a business out of a mobile
application and we decided to start
tapjoy to provide services to publishers
to help them build a business so today
we help with mobile
advertising and we provide services to
make it very easy to sell virtual goods
host a virtual currency and in general
profit from a mobile app start more
broadly and Bob I think you have a
unique view into the industry in general
in the sense you know looking at it from
the perspective of what platforms are
there and when and popular and kind of
what trends we see in that space you
know is is it Apple and Android and
everybody else is it i mean what where
do you think this is headed right now
well man every mobile conference i go to
that's the first question and the honest
answer is nobody really knows you know
what you can bet on is chaos and
fragmentation you can just bet on it i
think there's going to be an interesting
battle between sort of the more open
horizontal type platforms and then the
sort of more closed like apple and ram
versus sort of the open like have
the horizontal ones like windows mobile
and android and frankly both have their
values i think some people will choose
one some people choose another i
actually don't think any one of them is
really going to win i think it's just
going to be a big mess so whatever
strategy have you ought to count up
count on it being a mess frankly i
personally like that my company thrives
on the chaos the more chaos there is in
the mobile industry the more money we
make but but yeah it's they will all
have their place and frankly the level
of innovation competition and change
that's happening I think it's just gonna
be a mess and that's a good thing well I
think you know the market is kind of you
know very obviously slanted right now
toward Apple and I think you know
obviously a lot of folks are developing
to that platform syriac you guys just
created a very interesting application
maybe you could talk a little bit about
that and some of the behavior that
you're seeing yeah we we launched an
application that actually makes you feel
good and we thought that could be a
universal purpose and while it makes you
feel good it actually changes the world
which we thought might be even better so
it's called cause world like a good
cause ca us e and world so the what it
does
basically it's the first app that lets
you do good deeds simply for walking
into a store and the way it works is you
download a free app on your iPhone or
your Android phone and then you come
close to a store and you check in and
you say I'm here and then you earn cama
points so you're actually increasing
your comic just by going shopping so it
we're turning shopping into guilt-free
experiences and then you are you are
earning your commas and then the
interesting thing is what happens after
that because we're turning the Karma's
into real real world real money
contributions to charities you choose
one of your favorite charities on the
service there is currently 12 different
causes you can plant a tree in the
rainforest you can feed a family in
America you can help somebody in Haiti
you can help fight cancer and behind it
are all charitable organizations that
you may know like American Red Cross and
feeding feeding America and Lance
Armstrong's lift strong organization and
the the wonderful thing is that the
money that is actually fueling the
charity is not coming from you it comes
from big companies that have the money
so the initial donors are Citibank and
kraft foods they put half a million
dollars in to get it started and every
time you check in you get five Karma's
the five comas turn into a real money
contribution on the back end and we've I
think so far we've we have helped offset
800,000 pounds of carbon footprint
planted more than 50,000 helped plan
four hundred fifty thousand trees and
fed I think sixty thousand families in
the US and gave 30,000 people in Sudan
fresh water for an entire month and save
fifty thousand animals from injured
animals from pretty pretty much certain
death so it's actually a kind of a
wonderful experience for me personally
because
I've always dreamt of the idea of
actually using technology to change the
world and this is what's just supposed
for us to be a trial application because
we are in the intersection of mobile
meets retail and we were actually just
curious what you said what a consumer is
really willing to do with their cell
phone when they're out shopping and what
are they're not willing to do so we
created an application that needed
absolutely zero retailer integration
which is caused world and the way it
works is that big brands up are spending
the money on it and they're getting an
enormous marketing benefit because the
CPM rate is less than eight dollars on
it and you get personal engagements with
consumers actually the average Facebook
person has 130 friends so you can do the
math what happens if you take five
commas and get 131 people the person on
the cell phone and hundred thirty people
on facebook if they post it to their
feed so it's a very interesting platform
and what I find most exciting about it
is the fact that it actually if you
think about it like this like you put
you put marketing money in here and
charity money comes out on the right on
the other side of the app it's the first
platform that turns regular marketing
dollars directly into charity donations
one hundred percent which is kind of
cool and what do we learn about
consumers it's quite quite interesting
actually to observe what consumers want
to do with their phone for example we we
launched a badge you can earn badges for
doing certain things it's like a little
bit of like a game it's kind of fun and
so on Valentine's Day we said so spread
the love it's love day right and make
sure that you donate today and we give
you a special batch for that and people
just went nuts about it so it's it's
it's little things that matter to people
and it's actually quite encouraging also
to see what people really care about it
is not necessarily all about money and
you know selfishness people are actually
willing to do a lot to do to change the
world and that's it's pretty pretty cool
to see hey Syria kept the donors been
able to measure you know and very
analytical your quantity quantity kind
of the benefit there
seeing from this from from you know from
being associated with this yes they they
have and they actually demand that they
demand weekly reports and you know look
at every single result of course
initially for them it was kind of a
trial thing and you know tested a little
bit and see what happens and we were
very grateful that they would even do
that and now it turns out it's actually
a great marketing opportunity for them
because of this deep engagement just put
yourself for a second take yourself out
of the shoes of what you're currently
doing and put yourself in the shoes of
being a citibank person and there's all
this discussion about you know City and
financial industry and all that so now
you're bringing in cause world and
you're coming close to a store and
you're earning comma and it says made
possible by city and then you spent them
and you actually give somebody fresh
water and Sudan for an entire month and
it says made possible by city and then
you tell your friends about it on
Facebook and it says made possible by
Citibank that you just helped somebody
in Sudan for an entire month with fresh
water that is a personal engagement
level and an endorsement coming from you
to your friends that is so valuable from
a brand perspective it's it's so good to
be associated with these positive things
going on that's why it's actually worth
more I would post post post the simple
question if you were a market here would
you rather like to spend your money on a
billboard or on reading 131 people on
average with deep personal engagement
around changing the world and giving
somebody fresh water in Sudan and take
and while you're doing that people are
actually in a shopping mode because
they're getting close to stores they may
even use your citibank credit card while
they're shopping and you are using your
entire money that you otherwise would
have spent on the billboard for fresh
water in africa what would you rather do
and i think that is kind of the next
generation of marketing that then we
need to think about and mobile is the
tool to
personalize it and that's why mobile is
so exciting because you can do something
completely different that is more
location-based more personalized and and
that's very that's a very special thing
this is not the next small pc or the
next small television set there's a
completely new medium of its own right
thanks Syria that's a very interesting
model you know Lee I think you've got a
very unique perspective into developers
and publishers and and what they need
today and what they are trying to do
maybe you could talk a little bit about
what you're seeing and you know their
efforts to monetize their applications
sure so we work with almost a thousand
publishers an iphone and actually on
android now too and first and foremost
are seeing a lot of excitement so we
love working with these folks and you
know everyday people are coming up with
new exciting ways to take advantage of
smartphone devices and these new
platforms but there are real challenges
to building a business and you know if
you if you look at just that the size of
the of the bow the number of publishers
the number of applications for example
on the iphone um you know a couple
hundred thousand at this point and you
look at how many are actually building a
business there and can maintain
profitability or or generate revenue
it's a much smaller number um so we know
when we work with publishers on we
really like to have them think about
kind of a holistic a whole it take a
holistic view to what they're doing so
if it's it's just a hobbyist and they're
building the application that's great if
you want to build a business and
generate revenue you're gonna have to
think about the various sources of
revenue on and we kind of break it out
into really four categories one is just
paper download um this is basically
where we saw for example the App Store
on the iPhone and even the Android on
later are working with it turns out very
few companies right now are able to
build a profitable business on the paper
download model um so it it feels
enticing it feels like wow I can kind of
put out some content and have a small
payment brought back to me but it
on the number of users who are willing
to pay per download is something between
one-tenth to one twentieth the number of
users that are willing to just download
a free application so that's a big
barrier um so if you know it's one thing
to try that um but we often recommend
people take that you know holistic
hybrid approach so then there are
advertisements on and there's
traditional banner ads and that's
something that on there's a lot of
excitement about but what we're seeing
in the marketplace right the
intersection helping publishers with
advertisements is that right now there's
actually a much faster growth rate of
the inventory the number of eyeballs on
these devices and the duration these
eyeballs are looking at the devices then
there is the growth rate of the good
high paying ads so that that creates if
you will more supply of ad space then
there is demand right now for that ad
space and actually the supply is growing
faster than the demand which means that
adder eights in general are actually
going down on and so that's a it's a
interesting thing to consider and you
know I have some other thoughts on that
we can talk about later perhaps but so
that you know on the ad space it's
important to optimize your ads and
figure out on you know potentially using
multiple ad networks on figuring out
what kinds of ads will be more engaging
for your users the third way we help
publishers and we recommend the
publishers think about monetization and
how to build a business here is with
alternative types of of revenue so
virtual goods and virtual currency are a
really strong trend right now on mobile
and again you take advantage of the
users that come in for free to try your
product and on you almost upsell them
once they had a chance to look at it
with a virtual good it might be
unlocking some new functionality or it
might be a new level pack in a game or
it might be you know some other piece
that you want them to be able to
purchase on or you might have some sort
of virtual currency some virtual good on
currency system kind of like Siri x cos
world where you can earn karma points
and
on what you're doing is yours
encouraging users to interact more
through application and through that
process you're going to generate value
either it's for yourself as a publisher
or in Syria X case you know for the good
of humanity so so that that's the that's
the that's the third way and in the
fourth way that we're excited about
mobile sort of platform monetization is
on brand new types of a sort of
marketing action um that's what we call
it and we think that the mobile device
will be able to pull people into
commerce situations and transact perhaps
in the real world or even on their phone
and if you can if you can sort of
facilitate that with a mobile
application on bring someone into the
store to make a purchase or have
somebody even download another
application or any of these sort of
called marketing action activities
that's a great way so you know net net
on its it's hard to build a good
business on mobile right now is what
we're finding we work with hundreds of
publishers who struggle with it but um
there are a lot of avenues that are on
evolving and and creating opportunity
and my advice to publishers is to really
on look at all of them and try to find
as many of those ways to engage with
your user and create value on that it's
possible thanks thanks Lee maybe we
could spend another second on
advertising a myth that obviously that's
kind of a big topic but you know are we
seeing anything you know let's hit the
last six to nine months that kind of
leads us to think that things are
changing for advertiser or for
advertising in general in the mobile
world that you know in terms of getting
better to developers and publishers and
secondly you know you talked about kind
of optimizing for ads is one way to kind
of you know as a benefit but he maybe
talk a little bit about the multiple
networks and kind of specifically what
that what that yields yeah so we had a
crazy six months so we've seen two major
acquisitions that um were extremely high
multiples of gross revenue much west net
revenue on and you know those are
signals in the marketplace there's a lot
of investment there's a lot of energy
around
this ecosystem of putting ads on these
mobile devices where all these eyeballs
are looking so I think certainly the
last six months have been I don't know I
I'm new to the industry to be honest so
you know I've been in the industry for a
year last six months were an
acceleration of the previous six months
so that's my side data points you know
looking historically just the volume you
can look back the last ten years and you
know it is on a very steady growth curve
in terms of the again the inventory the
eyeballs on I think what's slower slower
moving are the the advertisers and um
and so you know there's there's a need
for better ad formats that match mobile
because taking just normal ads from the
web and putting it on mobile doesn't
always have the same effect so that's
one thing on we are seeing some
innovation they're so so video ads are
actually starting to be in coming to use
on mobile devices with 3g networks those
are exciting on we're seeing more on
location based at interest but not
nearly enough real innovation and real
delivery of that inventory on so you
know that's kind of the last six months
in terms of the ad networks and
optimization on you know we have a
unique position where we work with on 12
ad networks and we get to see what's
coming through their pipeline and then
on the other side we work with
publishers and we try to sit in the
middle and optimize if you will as a
mediation platform that's what app
that's one of Tapjoy services and um you
know there's less differentiation then
you would want in a very competitive
marketplace that's kind of one very high
level bit on too I'll say that the ads
are really broken up into two categories
performance ads and and sort of brand
ads and on and so you know brand ads are
folks who want you know folks like land
rover and Nike and Dell who buy based on
impression and their if different set of
metrics and they're trying to get sort
of awareness out there
performance ads are folks like other
publishers who want new users and
they're counting every click and
measuring every new conversion and
they're much more analytical and so
right now we're seeing that there's a
huge huge differentiation between those
two segments of advertisers and what
they're paying and effectively they're
both getting the same end product which
is a user eyeball looking at the same ad
format and taking some sort of action so
there you know this isn't not this is
not completely unique to mobile there's
always a differentiation between brand
advertising and performance advertising
in mobile though it's particularly
noticeable since the ads themselves are
so similar so you know there's going to
have to be some rationalization of that
and and so in today you know if you look
at the ad networks and sort of see what
they're doing some ad networks are
focusing on the brown dad's um but um
you know at the end of the day like most
of them are really all vying for the
same big-brand advertisers right now and
you can see it in their pipeline of ads
it's on it's just not that
differentiated so yeah that's that's all
right there thanks Lee yeah so Steve
I've got my advertising strategy all
worked out and I need users and I think
you talked about user acquisition is
obviously a key what's what are your
thoughts there and then what can we
advise the audience on that topic yeah I
think it's increasingly hard for a new
developer who puts a lot of time and
effort into one app when they put it out
there to get users because if you refer
if when the iphone launched if you put
out your app it could be virtually
anything and you would have a lot of a
lot of downloads because there wasn't
that many choices now the choices it's
so huge it's getting to be like the web
so how do people discover what I'm doing
how can i get one user and translate
that into thousands of users so that
those type of problems are the ones we
have to figure out now and I think on
the web we've seen a lot of different
mechanisms coming into play where you
can get users and kind of grow your user
base and on mobile we're just starting
to to play with that
so I know for a fact that some of my
partners in this project that were there
four of us there six of us who got
together from four different companies
and we actually been my partners have
been developing apps and putting them
out there in the app store and then
measuring what they can do in the App
Store to actually get more users to come
in and download their their products and
how they would translate one user that
they got into many more users through
connecting their different applications
together so we've done it's a product
called app thing and it hasn't launched
yet but the idea is we took that
knowledge and built out a platform so
that so that it would make it easier for
other developers to do the same thing to
kind of grow their user base and manage
that the other thing on the advertising
i think is very interesting to point out
is I actually think there's going to
continue to be a huge surplus of ad
inventory out there and so really the
way you're going to make money in mobile
will continue to be just selling your
app or selling a premium version of your
app or else through virtual goods which
you're working on I think virtual goods
are going to be just like we've seen in
the Facebook space argot you're going to
give away a free app and then you're
going to get people hooked and you're
going to upsell them on little pieces
and then there's one other area actually
in advertising that I think is really
going to a you know where you can really
command a premium because I see that the
CPM is coming down and down in the pop
cost per click it's still going to be
there's just so much inventory out there
but the one area where inventory won't
matter is if you make a very specific
app for a specific audience that is
highly valued by a certain group so for
example if you make an appt for doctors
that it has a lot of utility and
doughton you can market it directly to
all the doctors the drug companies who
pay you a lot of money to get to those
doctors to be on that screen and that is
independent of the huge inventory it
doesn't matter if you if you if you have
you know fifty thousand doctors using
your app and that's just one example or
pharmacists or other people and then you
have a certain group that wants to reach
them then you can make you could make it
independent of these ad networks you can
go directly to the brands that want
reach those people and command hi CPMs
gosh really is this is a structural
question that follows out there I'd be
interested in answering and I'm actually
curious about this so if you rewind 24
months ago this whole concept and out of
an app on mobile was sort of archaic
right everybody was sort of presuming
everything would go into the browser
right and if you sort of look at
everybody talks about apps now taps
doing this naps doing that it's actually
kind of a surprise if you sort of think
about where the mobile industry was 24
months ago that now we was talking about
native apps versus everything being
absorbed into the browser so if you
think there's two questions one is as
the mobile browsers improve rapidly with
things like html5 what's the implication
of that you know and then the second one
what does that mean for all these app
vendors what what do they become in a
world where the browser suddenly gets a
lot better well I see there's not a
clear line between absent and and you
know mobile web content um because you
know with all the developers I'm talking
to what they're doing is a lot of them
are building mobile web applications and
then they're wrapping them very quickly
in a nap and putting them into the App
Store and it's and then they'll
also have a mobile web version so it's
really just a way of the app stores in
kind of a way of marketing it sort of
hot link to it yeah okay through itunes
and if you're smart you know then you
have one codebase you can do a lot with
mobile web right now and it will get
even better so in the future I see
people just I mean I see them kind of
merging together and it's really the
best thing about the app is itunes
itself or then the App Store so what
does that do to this for the
monetization model if they stop from
being apps to being just another web
page out in the cloud becomes much
harder to sell them I thought that you
fit the small observation without given
the year selling to these guys yeah so I
think in the short run apps are still
very will be very interesting because of
the responsiveness the kind of focused
task that is involved with that the
small screen really means that discovery
of new applications is actually
and so the App Store really is the
marketing channel and it's and it's it's
easy to find and execute and interact
with apps they're also richer
experiences today and I actually believe
that will be the case for a while html5
is cool and great we need better
networks actually more than set more so
than the standards of the browser's we
need like you know better latency and
weed so there's some issues there on the
devices in wireless networks um I think
in general though you you want to build
an app that is connected and the line
does get kind of blurred and i agree
with stephen on that so uh you know
absolutely thing thanks guys you know
one thing that I've been wondering is
you know they're obviously there are
some great topics we've talked about in
terms of services when Moltres is the
right that are out there right now at
the Mobile World Congress I think Eric
Schmidt demonstrated in its keynote some
of the services that Google's you know
going to be providing such as voice
recognition and so forth over mobile
devices which is all amazing and very
cool are there other you know areas or
services that that we collectively
should be thinking about out there kind
of where we headed on that what's what's
new and interesting around the corner I
mean we've talked about location-based
what else is there that we should be
thinking about you know in the next six
to 12 months and anyone i would say a
couple of the areas that are really
interesting are some of the areas that
have been not looked at as much and they
are actually there's good reason why
they haven't been looked at it yet but
it may actually be just around the
corner which is what you asked so one is
mobile health care so very interesting
area just think of diabetes patients
uploading their sugar levels at all
times with an implant being connected to
doctors emergency services communities
self-help groups there's 25 million
people in the u.s. that have diabetes
that's just one disease a really good
epocrates is crushing it there's a bunch
of healthcare companies are investing
tons of money yeah so there's a lot of
opportunity the question is is it a
start of opportunity or not but that's a
different question the the second one is
probably achma
the reality but it's basically just a
continuation of what's already happening
with physical world meets meets mobile I
think that the intersection of mobile
and the physical world is really were
the biggest opportunity lies that's also
why we're working on mobile meets retail
and then maybe another opportunity is to
think about what cook consumers actually
do if their cell phones interacted
without them knowing about it every time
so they give permission once but then
they all connect and help each other you
probably remember that I found is a
brilliant model you know there is
there's always model and execution as
two different things but the model i
believe it was brilliant of dash where
you would drive down the street and you
know it would automatically upload you
know it's a navigation system in your
car it's not a cell phone but it's
connected to a wireless network and so
you're driving down the 280 and what do
you think is the reason when somebody
goes 35 miles an hour on the 280 so
let's assume there's two people who both
go 35 miles an hour in the same spot so
it's unlikely they're both drunk so
therefore it's probably a traffic jam
and everybody else gets informed
automatically and the navigation is
automatically rerouted for everybody
else was using the same network so
simply by being selfish and that's why
it's so brilliant just by being selfish
and wanting to be navigated you're
automatically helping everybody else who
also wants to be navigated and if you
think if you take that concept and you
scale it to other cons to other areas
that's a really interesting think I
believe so I think we're just in the
actually I believe we're the Stone Age
of mobile and if you think three years
ago you pointed this out a little bit
just the last six months or Lisa at six
months ago everything looked different
great companies like Lee's didn't exist
a year ago and today we're working with
them so another example is three years
ago the two biggest consumer facing
giants in Silicon Valley we're not even
really in mobile they're called Apple
and Google there was no i phone three
years
oh and two years ago there was no SDK
and you pointed it out there were no
apps because everybody sets mobile web
at the end of the day the consumer
simply does one little thing consumer
always goes where the best value is and
it's exactly how it should be so when we
discuss mobile mobile web versus
downloadable apps the answer is very
simple whatever the best experiences
will win and if it's simpler to start a
mobile web browser and faster and it's a
great experience the mobile web will win
and by the way likely over time that
will be the case right now why our
mobile app so cool because they're so
way better from a consumer experience
perspective than anything else that's
out there and why does the iphone win
because it's so way better than the
blackberry right now and so whatever the
consumer experience is wherever the leap
frogging happens the consumer will go
and the good news is that's exactly how
it should be because consumers always
right so in a nutshell if you think
ahead what will the landscape look like
in two to three years from now in mobile
if I phones didn't exist three years ago
so what will be there in three years
from today will it be ipod iphone
5-point o or will be will there be a
company we haven't even heard about and
I'm sorry to use me as a guinea pig but
his company didn't exist a year ago by
the way mine either so that means that
there will be new companies coming on
the on the scene and there's one big
topic that hasn't been cracked and
whoever is going to crack is going to go
into a gold mine which is mobile
virality you know that everything online
is about virality right and whoever
became big just think just think for a
moment who is viral ebay facebook
myspace you know twitter is all viral
stuff so if know if you if somebody can
crack for a reality on mobile which is a
much bigger problem than online you will
see a very interesting opportunity and
and the reason so difficult is because
of fragmented devices and Bob pointed
out earlier it's a big mess and he loves
it
but from the virality point of view that
is not very great so because you never
know which cell phone your friend has so
therefore it's not very easy to just
pass something on to them except you if
you want a text message and that's not
the native media richest experience the
world has seen so far so that means
there is there's a huge opportunity here
in virality and if that can be cracked
in the next few years it will be very
exciting and we are seeing some of those
things like if there is some form of
virality going on it's actually becoming
really interesting we haven't really
announced this publicly very much the
first time I'm saying this in front of a
group that I don't know personally but
our service has reached the number of
users and the number of usage the amount
of usage that foursquare needed 10
months for win we did that in two months
so we just haven't talked about it so in
other words there is a there's
significant opportunities once you get
this dynamic going a little bit and I'm
not saying we've cracked it but if you
get a little closer this huge
opportunity built yeah I would build on
you know the area i think is that's
really interesting is like you were
saying see rak thai a mobile type to the
physical world and in particular i'm
really interested in the idea of
intention tied to proximity so if I I
would you know the phones if you kind of
imagine what are the phones of the
future going to be doing for you well
they will kind of know what you want
what your intention is in the things
that you want and they will match that
with your location and your proximity to
other people and services in your area
so for example you know if you're at a
conference let's say here today and
there are certain people that I want to
connect with that type of person and I
can let my device know that I want to
meet those people then it can let those
other people the conference know that oh
I have this and you have that and put us
together and those could be people that
I have a relationship with that I know
so oh I didn't know you were at this
conference is great we can we can meet
up the top or it can be other people who
I wanted
business with but haven't met yet and
they're doing a certain thing that
matches with mine and then if you take
that outside of just a conference but
you apply it to the real world where
you're going you know looking for
products and services and you're walking
through the world and your mobile device
can say it's a certain time of day I
know it's a certain hour so you're in
your work mode and I and you want to
accomplish this well these are the
things that you'll be interested in and
it brings them to you that is going to
be a really an exploding area across the
smartphone devices that you can't do
with your laptop or PC or anything else
yeah leave off any thoughts on this
earth I agree with those those topics I
think there is a couple other
interesting ones one is survey services
just help you navigate your life um and
you know they're potentially is room for
a you know similar to the productivity
suite being kind of the killer app for
desktop something that is related to
your management of your life but on your
mobile device and the fact that it's
with you at all times and can have
contextual information or information
about your history on you know that
realm gets excited setting to me on in
addition you know I'm interested in
things that help everyday transactions
and inefficiencies go away because
everyone has a computer in their pocket
so if you're standing in line somewhere
if that can be avoided if you are you
know are trying to you know if you're
with a business in the real world and
and and you can provide the forms filled
out without you know doing paper so the
stuff that kind of we the exchanges of
information that happen every every
couple hours all throughout the day on
using the computer in our pocket to make
that like incredibly more efficient
interesting is something that I'm
interested in to theirs
I think there's another thing that's
probably useful to think of in mobile if
you sort of get outside the perspective
of a bunch of 30 to 40 year olds in
Silicon Valley in New York I think it's
sort of important to apply that lends to
mobile because mobile fundamentally is
one of the few truly global technology
phenomena since the Internet in the
browser and the reality is there are
huge giant industries and lots of people
that don't behave like we do I think
it's important to sort of remember that
in terms of thinking about unaddressed
markets I think the point about
healthcare being transformed by mobile
there are things like that there I think
that's an interesting business
opportunity there is to look at big
markets of old people and how is mobile
gonna affect that or markets in Europe
where you know people use mobile
differently or go to Asia and be
thinking about it a give you an example
you know why smartphones aren't really
catching on korea with qwerty keyboards
because the Korean language actually
works really well on a little 9 pad kee
right like so there's like really subtle
things like that on a global basis that
it's important to sort of remember
everybody's not like us and I think in
doing that and sort of thinking about
the opportunities and mobile I'm not
even sure what they all are because I
still look at lunch to the ones of a 32
four-year-old Silicon Valley guy but I
think for those of you that come from
other places or interested in other
markets I think one of the really big
opportunities is to take a step back and
think about how is mobile going to
transform healthcare how its mobile
going to transfer transform things like
manufacturing how is it going to
transfer things like you know you know
retirement you know whatever it is so
you know frankly I don't me really good
ideas there but one of the good
strategies and sort of entrepreneurship
is to go where people aren't and look
for the places where people aren't
necessarily piling in yeah Bob great
point you know I think there's there's
one set of people that we really haven't
addressed in this whole equation yet and
I think they would probably not not be
happy about that and those are the folks
that exactly those are the folks that
are responsible for the massive amounts
of data that we're trading amongst
ourselves and what I'm wondering is you
know obviously there are new models now
of how we're interacting with them we're
trying to you know detach phones from
from carriers etc
but surely they must be up to something
here what's the panel's thoughts on how
this is going to evolve obviously we're
asking for a lot of bandwidth for these
services and but we don't want any paid
a lot more for it I mean what it wears
is highlighted I think have the current
rate the cost per bit is actually too
high and the current we face that at CBS
for example when we build CBS mobile we
had a lot of video content because it's
kind of the nature of the business so
when you want to transmit CSI over a
cell phone which is a you know usually
about a 46 minute addition that's a
problem because at the end of the time
at the end of the 46 minutes the carrier
has probably lost about ten dollars so
it's not a feasible model but I don't
think the answer is to say that we are
now going to be charged on a per bid
basis because that's not going to fly
with consumers and that means you are
actually killing the market the answer
is we need better technologies that have
lower costs for bid rate prices and that
is already being worked on as you as you
probably all know with LTE and LTE is
really a game changer in many ways if I
don't know if you guys have seen a
demonstration of LTE we're talking about
speeds that are you know not too far off
on what you know from your office and at
that point the cost per bit rate is
becoming affordable it's very
interesting by the way when you think
about other cultures how some cultures
may actually you know how it is in some
parts of Asia as a lot of people have
never had a regular telephone but they
jump to directly to mobile right I I
experienced that last year I two years
ago I went through the through some
crazy plays like Putin and the Amazon
jungle and when I got there they
literally were you know chatting away on
texting we're on the cell phones at
10,000 feet altitude the monks at the
monasteries in Bhutan and that only had
cell phones for four years because
before that it just didn't exist and
they had previously been away from their
families for months without ever talk
to them now they were texting back and
forth but the interesting thing is that
these guys jumped directly over the land
line and over the PC to the cell phone
so now if you take this further and you
think about what does that mean for the
rest of the world some parts of the
world like the Amazon jungle for example
is still largely without a cell phone
network simply because it doesn't make
sense from an economic point of view to
put up all these towers because they're
not a lot of people there right so those
areas may actually jump directly from 0
and 2 LTE because the area is much wider
that you can cover and the economics are
different and in those areas today
they're using hollow trees to
communicate I'm not actually joking
there you know tapping against the tree
and have Morse codes to to tell each
other what's going on because there's no
other except to sell light phone maybe
but that's too expensive is it doesn't
work very well in the jungle so the
opportunity comes along to get rid of
this data issue as you improve the
network quality and that's really the
biggest threat to the future of the
industry i believe if we don't go fast
enough there because we can't keep going
at the current rate it's just not really
affordable and as much as we all like to
bash carriers because it's so much fun
it's actually not very reasonable
because from an economic point of view
it simply is not affordable any other
thoughts Bob well I you know I worked
for a while you know a long time with
the carriers and it was a you know they
had the ball in their hand they could
have they had the app store they had the
direct connection to the consumer that
you you know they had the billing
mechanisms and Apple just stole the show
because the carrier's never figured it
out they never they never really
supported or engage the developer
community my fear you know as a
developer is that Apple will you know
wind up becoming more and more like the
carriers of the old day and I think you
know there's been a big controversy
I don't know if you've been following it
but lately the big controversy this past
week with Apple was there all the the
bathe that they put out there and Apple
just pulled them over night I mean
literally you know they're there
literally these applicants are pretty
tame there you know you know swimsuits
and you know bikinis things like that
they're an apple just decided you know
overnight we're going to pull all of
these and there are a lot of independent
developers tens of thousands who are
making money on these and overnight
they're just ripped down from the app
store while they let the big brand stay
so playboy and all these Maxim and with
exactly the same content got to stay in
the app store so if you look at that
that's a danger for both Apple because I
don't think they that you know they
really fought through it very carefully
and it's also a danger for developers
many of whom you know it's part of their
livelihood they're independent so but
that's just emblematic of you know what
can happen the beauty of what I see the
apples done is they have like one device
and it's consistent and you upload it to
one app store and it works whereas the
carriers and you're actually seeing this
problem with google the Android is all
these different devices with different
screen sizes and configurations and then
you have to start porting it to all
these different devices so there's this
big there's this big trade-off and I
think the tension that we're going to
see over the next year between these is
going to be really interesting yeah that
battle between control and fragmentation
yes control and fragment it is makes
your head hurt yeah good um why don't we
cover one other topic and then maybe
take some questions and that is where I
think each of you has raised money from
the VC world any advice for the audience
as folks walk down that path in this
field raising money in this area
many specifics on that bathroom anyone
well I I I raise money many times did
three different venture funded startups
I'm also currently helping five
different early very early-stage
entrepreneurs with their companies
advising them and I can see the struggle
because it's gotten much harder to raise
money in today's environment that it was
a couple years ago so a couple years ago
you could step in with a great idea and
kind of a rough prototype and you could
get funded today the venture capitalists
absolutely you have they have to see
your use they want two things they want
the number one is revenue growth but
they will fund you without revenue
growth if you have exceptional user
growth you know people are just using
your your website or your app like crazy
but without those what they call
traction it's you know you're almost
wasting your time going out for funding
and in a way the whole venture model has
isn't really working the way it was
intended to because there aren't a lot
of big value exits over a hundred
million dollars just IPOs or
acquisitions they're more sub 100
million dollars and that model for the
venture capitalist doesn't make sense
they need big exits they are betting on
a few blockbuster hits like Facebook and
Twitter style hits they're not betting
on a lot of 20 million dollar
acquisitions that that's a waste of
their time and they actually you know
they often lose money on those type of
deals so if you're an entrepreneur out
there though and you you know honestly
you should be looking at this that the
five to fifty million dollar acquisition
range because that's a lot of money
especially if you didn't take venture
capital and have these big liquidation
preferences so what I'm telling the
entrepreneurs out there is don't even
waste your day all every entrepreneur
now graduating from business schools
like I'm going to go out I'm going to
get funded you know it's going to happen
i'm going to get my millions of dollars
and we're going to be the next Twitter
but it's very rare it probably won't
happen and even if it does even if you
do it won't and even if you do get the
money you may not end up getting much
out of it at by the time your company
actually sells for 30 million dollars
because you've taken in 30 million in
financing and you don't get anything so
it's really how do you build your model
on on on getting revenue early
bootstrapping it and hopefully exiting
for even a few million dollars is great
after a couple years you're not going to
get paid that so I think that figuring
that out right now is is what
entrepreneurs need to be doing really
well said Stephen any other thoughts on
that or yeah I would probably add one
one thing I would say there I think
there's two different models in the
market and both can make sense so one is
the model of where you that you just
described that that Stephens talking
about where you have an idea and you
know that a mobile there's a lot of
small to medium sized companies there's
love to garage to people in the garage
businesses that by the way are doing
very well for two people but they're not
scalable to a large company size so it
really depends on whether you want to go
that route or the other route is you try
to develop an idea that has the
potential and of course you never know
and as you said it's like playing the
lottery to start this company and let's
face it right you do that you can't do
that for the money you have to do it
because you love it but let's assume you
love it that doesn't mean you still you
have the the right thing for the second
approach the second approach is you have
an idea that has the potential to become
a very large company the potential and
then when you have that idea and by the
way I think there's not there's not an
infinite number of those ideas
especially not in mobile I talked about
device fragmentation earlier you talked
about the mess that means that you need
to find new approaches and find the
right areas to go into but there are
such opportunities if you believe you
have an idea like that then venture
funding is probably very hopeful because
it helps you scale much faster that
otherwise you could and some of those
models also need for example entries to
large partners hard to do if you are a
one
or two-man band in Silicon Valley right
and it's very helpful to get the support
from the right people for that it
depends on your business idea so now
then the next question is where is the
ER what are your chances of actually
getting the funding if let's assume you
love it and you have the great idea now
the next question is how do you get the
money and basically on that front I
think it's two things that an
entrepreneur needs to do one is you got
eliminate risk and to you got to build
assets those are the two things in
entrepreneur does every day you got to
eliminate risks and you talked about
consumer traction that's one risk
equally limited another one is you could
have a partnership with a big player
already lined up there are certain ways
you can try to eliminate risks and for
each business that is a different set of
risk it's not always the same thing it
depends on what you want to do and then
how to build assets think about assets
what kind of assets could you create
that very quickly give you an advantage
in the market over other people so if
you tell your grandmother about what you
have achieved in the last six months
what would be the biggest thing you
could have done in six months and how
could you how could you build this
business from nothing it's essentially
that's the art of an entrepreneur right
you create something out of hot air
that's really what you're doing that's
the job and most people think that's
daunting and crazy and it is both and
then the question is okay are you up for
it you still want to do it and if you
want to do it and you feel that's really
right up right your thing to create
something out of nothing then you are
probably an entrepreneur and then you
got to find out whether you can actually
pull it off and so the next big question
for you is are you a chicken and egg
breaker because good entrepreneurs are
chicken and egg breakers you probably
have you've probably heard that many
times that yeah well if you had some
users i would give you some advertising
money well if i had some partners then i
could get users well okay the big
partner says well what do you have to
offer me why should I work with you
today and the user says what is on your
service why I should use it and there is
no answer to either question because
you're sitting there with hot air around
you so in other words you got a fine
a way to break the chicken and egg
problem and that's what you have to do
every day so in other words to sum it up
again you basically do two things you
you eliminate risks and you build assets
and the how-to is to break chicken and
egg problems and that's what you do
every day and one thing that maybe I
don't know if this is interesting to you
but I think that one of the main things
I believe in entrepreneur needs to be
willing to do as an as a person as an
individual is to be laughed at because
for a while nobody will take you
seriously no matter what you do when Lee
started his business one year ago he was
a student he was doing it in his dorm
room some people found that really cool
but Alice didn't know much about it
you'll probably hear loud more about him
in the next few years so that is what
that's the art of entrepreneurship you
do something although nobody else cares
and and most people don't take it
seriously and for a long time you're
probably not going to get any traction
so if you think entrepreneurship is
glamorous think again because ninety
percent of the time is hard work and
just slogging it up the hill and
creating something out of nothing and
the ten percent are much better than
what you ever get if you're not employed
I can promise you that too so there is
the highs are higher the lows are lower
the in other words the variance is much
larger I believe it's absolutely worth
every minute of it but that's your
choice yeah I actually had a great
experience with the venture capital
industry actually so we raise 20 million
dollars a day will probably raise
another 10 it's actually been pretty
straightforward for us actually the
first two guys who saw the deals to coin
or west funded it both our series a and
series be so you might ask why was that
versus some of the coming
nice if you can find something that's
structural in the industry those can
become really big companies look for
structural shifts major markets being
created stuff like that if it's it you
want to play play on the big games like
VC guys will fund those all day long and
you know I've actually had great luck
raising venture capital money but I
think you're right there is sort of this
bifurcation going on with there's sort
of these micro startups and you know 20
30 million dollar exits and then there's
the bigger plays and frankly that's just
sort of a decision for each of you is to
sort of what do you want to do but you
know the venture capital funding model
has changed that the PowerPoint
presentation getting 20 million bucks is
a little unusual my advice would be find
somebody to fund you for 300 400 500
thousand dollars a seed money and build
a prototype if you have a prototype that
you can show people to at least make the
concept real that will drastically
change sort of your velocity inside the
venture capital industry and yeah the
model has changed but you know don't
give up on them they actually have had a
great experience yeah um so my motto is
to pay people like syriac to talk about
me in public and then I got lots of
interest really else is this model um so
what we did was exactly what Bob said
which was you took a little bit of money
from someone that was very very helpful
a guy named Dave Wharton on and we were
able to just keep iterating until we
basically became cash flow positive and
then that gives you leverage to keep
working and build a lot of value well
build as much value as you can and not
have to be under time pressure which is
a really good place to be when you're
trying to raise money is um not that you
need it but that if you took it look how
much bigger the business could grow so
um that's that's my advice yeah I know
great points everyone in and you know
let me just
my two cents which is to your point
about traction Steve there's no quote
we'd see a lot of deal flow and for the
deals that we that we see that have
quote-unquote the traction you know
they're just getting multiple term
sheets from top-tier investors for the
ones that don't nothing and it's just
it's it's a pure binary formula right
now so why don't we open it up for
questions from all of you I think we've
been doing a lot of talking observe yeah
sure big opportunity of mobile needs
reality which I totally agree because
now more local based advertising comes
to the game the question is more selling
these to these advertisers because we're
then we are talking about the long till
we're talking about small and
medium-sized enterprises which are not
in the online marketing is real all
right now so what's the status quo you
see that's a great question so the whole
notion of mobile of mobile advertising
for local is a is a whiteboard
opportunity meaning it looks great on
the whiteboard and then you go go into
reality after that so there that doesn't
mean there is no models though but it
requires a it's it's not this this one
is an example of where it's not about
the business opportunity as a problem
you know like some other ideas maybe not
have such a big market opportunity it's
about how to go to market so there are
some approaches that are very
interesting in this field how you could
go to market but so far they have been
there has been Yelp of course right and
Yelp is probably closest to it but yelp
has some other issues you know right now
you know the with the with the local
advertisers as you probably might have
followed and there may be married or not
hopefully there's not but they're it's a
big market with a lot of players
involved and you have to find an
interesting go-to-market strategy and so
far I have not seen the one that can
really break that chicken and egg
problem because it's the classic example
was that so I would say my town is
actually a great great example because
they they have been able to build up a
user base incredibly fast very
impressive and I don't know exactly
they're an iphone company as well but I
don't know exactly where what their
focus is going forward whether that's
the market for them or not yet that's
their decision I'm not I'm suggest not
sure whether it is what they want to do
with regards to foursquare i think it's
a it's a very interesting development
the question that that i would pose is
how scalable it is for in terms of the
user base how many people want to
participate because there is there's
always a little bit of a difference
between PR and reality in some cases is
larger than others and it's important to
to check that because you know the if
you want to build something that really
attracts a lot of stores think about the
mom and pop shop in Kentucky that store
is only going to join if there is
thousands of users in that town that are
participating it doesn't matter to that
store whether you have 300 or 500
thousand users in the United States it
doesn't matter it's only relevant how
many users you have in that city and so
that remains to be seen i would say and
i also don't know whether that's their
model as well because it seems to be
more like a game and i'm not sure what
what the model is so we'll we'll see i
guess but both are very interesting
examples and i think it shows you the
direction of where the potential
opportunities are in that space
yeah every store in every city it's just
impossible we have to do is mobilize
your users and incentivize them to
become your sales force so they have to
walk into the shop and say get this on
here and you know convince the shop
owners to do that yes so I phone
generated the iphone also evolution
generated new business models and based
on your discussions with with vendors
like Qualcomm I affair we and others
what do you see next evolution and what
Jesus wants with that enable and insane
question we talked a lot about about the
market and mobile growth is in emerging
markets like Asia and Africa I don't see
someone in Africa trading virtual goods
what what are the business call out
there for emerging markets did you um
you know I'm not really an expert of
that I just know that they're not like
us so it's important sort of put that
lens on yeah I've seen a bunch of folks
spend time on in particular financial
services in developing markets because
you know mobile mobile payments if you
think about it the combination of lack
of infrastructure communications the
same lack of infrastructure about access
to capital moving money around so you're
actually seeing some really interesting
things happen there some is that some of
that's actually been handled by really
big companies and banks some of that's
actually smaller companies trying to
figure out that's a big structural gap
in some of the developing markets I
think the point syriac had about some of
these developing markets are going to
leapfrog right to LTE and have much
higher bandwidth if you can sort of
figure out which ones are likely to go
first it's good place to go move and
figure out what to do about it the was
the first part of the question
based on the other sessions with the
whole bed bangles you know this whole
thing about figuring out how to master
fragmentation feels like a huge
opportunity it's a nasty thorny one but
you know the reason why I app on the App
Store is done so else to your point they
sort of control the experience and
narrative to one device and said your
app badge has to be 91 pixels by 91
pixels so I think it's 91 x 91 isn't it
like seriously it's that specific you
know but the reality is mobile is going
to be fragmented so if you can figure
out something that fundamentally cuts
across all of those and can be
horizontal across all those that
increases your velocity increases your
market size so company I think there's
going to be an interesting focus of
companies trying to figure out how to do
that yo good example is like we actually
built an enterprise app store sounds
kind of boring right what the hell is an
app store for an enterprise but if you
think about the enterprise is living the
reality of their users have all sorts of
different platforms it's not like an
enterprise can say hey we're going to
build an app for the iPhone everybody
else is out of luck right so how do you
actually create things that are
horizontal across this fragmentation
feels like a big opportunity you know
there's interesting things happening
when you go to other places that you
might not have thought about and not all
of those by the way our startup
opportunities i'm just sharing them
because it shows you the range of things
happening so for example in south africa
you turn on the TV and the first thing
you see is a legal advice show and
there's lawyers on the screen yeah new
business model and they are giving you
advice for your issues and you text them
in so in other words there is not even a
telephone connection you just text your
issue in and then the lawyers start
talking about and maybe they even give
you a phone call back and give you sell
your advice sell their advice by the
hour so that's that's one thing that
we're mobile changes the game mobile
banking obviously really important as
you pointed out because many people
don't have bank accounts it's their
computer they don't have a pc this is
the way to shift it around that's the
that's more in the developing world but
if you think about the developed world
where
are the big opportunities that we first
part of your question I think it all
starts with what is the cell phone about
and how is it drastically different from
any other media platform that's where it
begins what is the use case let me give
you an example so at CBS for example we
have the issue that CBS is traditionally
used to be a television company so there
is two or three hours of primetime TV
that's the job right entertain people
from eight to eleven pm plus Letterman
so what do you do in the meantime so
today what happens is you wake up in the
morning I personally don't have my hands
available in the morning because I'm in
the kitchen and I'm always late so there
is no time for me to do it hold anything
so the media that I can use our radio
and television and in most cases the TV
is a radio in the morning and nothing
else because you don't really look at
you just listen to it then you are in
the car and use your cell phone or you
know of course in the driver in the
passenger seat then you are then you are
at work and you use your pc and you lean
forward and you want lots of options you
want to drill down and click on you
expect a lot of different menu items and
all that if that weren't there you would
say what a crappy application then you
go for lunch and if you are not if you
don't have a lunch date then you're
sitting there by yourself what do you do
cell phone now let me give you 15 menu
options and each one has ten sub-options
what do you how do you feel about that
and then you go back to work you sit in
from your computer again then you drive
home same thing then you come home and
lean back on your couch and you want no
options just TV big screen please don't
give me any options and then you go to
bed and you check your cell phone again
my point is same person one and the same
individual it's you and you have to
seamlessly migrate audiences from
platform to platform to platform and
entertain people for 18 hours a day not
for three that's the job of a media
company today but the story is that each
of the situations that you're in has a
very different user experience but the
user is the same and so if you think
about mobile what is different about
mobile is it a small pc well no it's not
is that a small television set
no it's not what is it well it's a new
medium it has location has social it has
context it's completely different it has
a small screen and by the way that's not
just a hurdle that's an opportunity as
well so in other words when you think as
an entrepreneur what can you do today
that you could never do before and
that's that's where you where you need
to come from from a consumer perspective
from a consumer perspective what is the
natural use case why do you think we're
in mobile meets retail because there are
things you can you have never been able
to do when you're out shopping until
today that's where the opportunity is
and I think those people who think
Mobile is a small pc or small TV are
missing out on about eighty to ninety
percent of the opportunity to me it's
like putting the new york times on
television what an interesting channel
to watch isn't it so who would have
thought about when TV came well why
don't we just have a newspaper channel
it's a new medium so we got to use it
and make use of everything in there by
the way it's also one of the most social
media ever invented because it's
probably the only medium you've ever
bought only to be social and it has your
entire social graph building it's called
cell phone book so everything is already
there now we got to play with it that's
the challenge and that's where the next
big opportunity is think of mobile as an
ID card for example you walk into your
house and a TV should automatically pop
up and say you know hide hi dog how was
your day here's your TV shows that i
recommend for today so it's because your
ID card you don't hand yourself on to
anybody else to think about all the
functionalities that have never been
tapped and to I have one other thing to
add in in foreign markets like if you're
looking out overseas and you want to
look for an opportunity I think the next
big wave there is going to be for a very
low priced smartphone so right now in
the foreign markets you know nokia
dominates right their phones are pretty
primitive but i'll tell you nokia is
looking for a way to beat apple and and
i bet that they're going to i would keep
my eye out for when nokia comes out or
one of the other manufacturers comes out
with a very low price
phone that Justin takes the third world
by storm and if you and if it starts to
go you know these phones start to sell
like crazy and India and China and other
places Africa is a little harder but
definitely in India and China and
countries like that in Brazil you will
see a huge opportunity to get your apps
out on that very low price smartphone
and if you're one of the first people to
put your apps out there you'll make a
lot of money look great thought maybe
one more question yeah sure I see at the
moment is in the gps to start its way to
the precise around you what you want to
do result from an interaction it's a
with b town do you think there's going
to be an opportunity when you and I
think I want to be able to walk around
to safeway am I going to be able to tell
me where my cookies are the show
and that's going to be an interaction of
that virtual reality targeted is
actually taken photos showing plus
essentially Mike revocation services
with insults do you see that as being
that best opportunity we're using my
summer vacation yes those are they're
very big opportunity for solving those
problems right now so you'll you'll see
a big shift in the next year or so great
well I'm time yeah well thank you to the
panel so we could okay thank you